We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Strange, isn't it? Well, from the point of view of physics, it will seem a little less strange.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加利福尼亚州乃至全球范围内合作创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。更多信息请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。这里是“99%看不见”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。很奇怪，不是吗？嗯，从物理学的角度来看，这似乎就没那么奇怪了。
Finding new ways to create new buildings with new technology has been the bread and butter of the leading edge architects since there have been leading edge architects. And today my friend Nate Domeo, a Nate, Hey Rowan, has the story of one of those men, a man whose time on the leading edge was brief but dramatic. Nate is the creator of the memory palace, a history podcast that is all about being brief and dramatic. This is the story of visionary Daredevil architect Bradford Gilbert. Take it away. Take it away. Bradford Gilbert had spent his career close to the ground.
寻找利用新技术建造新建筑物的新方法，一直是顶尖建筑师的核心业务，自从有顶尖建筑师以来就是如此。今天，我的朋友内特·迪梅奥（Nate Dimeo，Nate：“嘿，罗曼”）带来了其中一个人的故事，这个人在前沿领域的时间虽然短暂但却非常戏剧性。内特是历史播客《记忆宫殿》的创作者，该播客的核心就是简短而戏剧性。这就是富有远见的无畏建筑师布拉德福德·吉尔伯特（Bradford Gilbert）的故事。交给你了。布拉德福德·吉尔伯特的大部分职业生涯都是在底层度过的。
At 23 he took a job as the architect for the New York Leake Eri in Western Railroad. It was 1878. As an older man, he would redesign Grand Central Station. But his early 20s saw him designing less grand stations in less central locations. The places you waited to get places where things actually happened. But by a ticket for Manhattan or St. Louis or Chicago, and you could find other architects building
23岁时，他接受了一份工作，担任纽约伊利湖和西部铁路公司的建筑师。那是1878年。年长后，他将重新设计中央车站。但20出头时，他在不太核心的地方设计着不太宏伟的车站。那些你等待去往某个地方、事情真正发生的地方。买一张去曼哈顿、圣路易斯或芝加哥的车票，你会发现其他建筑师在建造
more impressive things, six and eight and 10 story structures, mammoth blocks of stone and brick in Rod Iron, made for the kings of the modern American insurance industry. The Emperor is of imports and exports. John Noble Sterns had made a lot of money importing silk, and he was looking to make a lot more in real estate. He bought some land in a prime location at 50 Broadway.
更令人印象深刻的东西，比如六层、八层和十层的建筑，由猛犸般的石块、砖块和熟铁制成，专为现代美国保险业的巨头们建造。进出口帝王约翰·诺布尔·斯特恩斯（John Noble Sterns）通过进口丝绸赚了大钱，他正寻找在房地产领域赚更多钱的方法。他在百老汇50号的黄金地段买下了一些土地。
But there was a problem. The lot was only 21 and a half feet wide. There are rules that dictate what you can build and how. Rules of physics and rules of men who sit on various bureaucratic boards and bodies. And those rules dictated that if Sterns wanted to build one of those ten story towers that were all the rage in 1888, he would need to build walls of stone and brick that were five feet thick. And that left room for an interior that was only 11 feet wide.
但问题来了。这块地只有21.5英尺宽。有一些规则规定了你能建什么以及如何建造。物理规则，以及坐在各种官僚委员会和机构中的人们制定的规则。这些规则规定，如果斯特恩斯想建造1888年风靡一时的十层高楼之一，他需要建造5英尺厚的石墙和砖墙。这样留给内部的空间就只有11英尺宽了。
Slice off a few feet for a hallway, a few for a bathroom, a couple for a coat closet, another for some filing cabinets and an umbrella stand. And he would be asking the quintessential modern Titan of American industry to work in a dark cell better suited for a dark age's monk. Sterns asked all the best architects for a solution and they all told them it couldn't be done. Everyone except Bradford Gilbert. The in-house architect for the New York Lake Erie in Western Railroad had a theory. Hundreds of tons of cars and cargo were hurtling over
切掉几英尺做走廊，几英尺做浴室，几英尺做衣帽间，再切掉一些做文件柜和雨伞架。这就等于要求美国现代工业的典型泰坦在一个更适合黑暗时代僧侣的黑暗牢房里工作。斯特恩斯向所有最好的建筑师寻求解决方案，他们都告诉他这不可能做到。除了布拉德福德·吉尔伯特之外的所有人。这位纽约伊利湖和西部铁路公司的内部建筑师有一个理论。每天有数百吨的汽车和货物呼啸而过
tiny train trestles every day. What if he turned one of those bridges on its head? What if he built a bridge up instead of out? He told Sterns that if he turned one of those bridges on its head? What if he built a bridge up instead of out? He told Sterns that if he did this, the walls wouldn't have to be five feet thick. They could be just nine inches each, and in the 20-foot wide office spaces that that would create, the quintessential modern American Titan of industry would have room to stretch out his legs. While he made his rant check out to John Noble Sterns, architects came in from all over the country to watch the tower building rise
微型火车栈桥每天都在经历考验。如果他把其中一座桥倒过来呢？如果他向上建桥而不是向外建桥呢？他告诉斯特恩斯，如果他这样做，墙壁就不必有5英尺厚。它们每堵墙只需要9英寸厚，由此创造的20英尺宽的办公空间里，美国现代工业的典型泰坦将有空间舒展双腿。当他把支票开给约翰·诺布尔·斯特恩斯时，来自全国各地的建筑师纷纷涌来观看这座塔楼的崛起
to pour over Gilbert's blueprints and they all pretty much agreed. Gilbert and Sterns were idiots. Sterns begged Gilbert to change the plans, but he refused. He said he was so confident in his design that he would move his offices to the top two floors of the building
仔细研究吉尔伯特的蓝图，他们几乎都一致认为：吉尔伯特和斯特恩斯都是白痴。斯特恩斯恳求吉尔伯特修改计划，但他拒绝了。他说他对自己的设计非常有信心，甚至要把自己的办公室搬到大楼的最顶两层
The building blew down. You would have the farthest of fall The first stiff winds of a hurricane blew into Manhattan on a Sunday morning in 1889 The tower building stood nearly complete And people lined the streets to watch it tumble A man pushed through the crowd and began to climb to watch it tumble. The man pushed through the crowd and began to climb. When Bradford Gilbert reached the top of his tower, the wind was whipping through its skeleton frame at more than 80 miles an hour, he crawled out to the center of the building and pulled from a bag, a rope, with a lead weight attached to one end. He tied the other to a
大楼会被吹倒的。你将会摔得最惨。1889年星期天的早晨，飓风的第一阵硬风吹进曼哈顿。塔楼几近完工，人们在街上排队观看它倒塌。一个男子穿过人群开始往上爬，去观看它倒塌。男子穿过人群开始往上爬。当布拉德福德·吉尔伯特到达他的塔顶时，狂风以每小时80多英里的速度穿过其骨架结构，他爬到大楼中心，从包里掏出一根带有一端附有铅坠的绳子。他把另一端绑在
girder and tossed the weight down through the open floors below. When he crawled his way back down, he found the lead weight hanging in the air, stock still, held up by a building that wasn't going anywhere. For years after, Gilbert could sit in his penthouse office in the still standing tower building and stretch out his legs and watch a whole city stretch ever higher. Taking his idea and building on it. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Nate Dimeo. I'm your host, Roman Mars. This program is made possible with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW, the American Institute of Architects, San Francisco, and the Center
大梁上，把铅坠从下方开阔的楼层扔了下去。当他爬下来时，他发现铅坠悬在空中，纹丝不动，被一座哪儿也不会去的大楼撑着。此后多年，吉尔伯特可以坐在仍然耸立的塔楼大楼顶层公寓办公室里，伸展双腿，看着整座城市不断拔地而起。采纳他的想法并在此基础上进行建设。《99%看不见》本周由内特·迪梅奥制作。我是你的主持人罗曼·马尔斯。本节目的制作得到了Lunar的支持，通过创意创造不同。这是KALW、美国建筑师协会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的合作项目
for Architecture and Design. To find out more, and get a link to Nate DeMail's brilliant memory palace podcast, go to 99%invisible.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
欲了解更多信息并获取内特·迪梅奥出色的《记忆宫殿》播客链接，请访问 99%invisible.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。